[Música]
la muerte de jevgeni
priginal para su destino al líder del
grupo de mercenarios más famoso desde
las pelis de Silvestre Stalone le
perdieron sus ambiciones de poder y se
metió con el tipo equivocado Vladimir
Putin el kremlin marca mucho y ser El
heredero de gobernantes como Simeón el
soberbio e Ivan el Terrible debe de ser
una enorme fuente de atrevimiento y ego
personal el actual zar de Rusia e
Invasor del este de Ucrania ha reunido
méritos más que suficientes como para
ser recordado como Vladimir el vengativo
la factura de prigo sin por su
particular marcha sobre Moscú ya ha sido
pagada sin embargo queridos amigos
todavía quedan muchas preguntas sin
respuesta respecto al futuro del grupo
Wagner han perdido a su rostro visible
pero aún hay miles de mercenarios
desplegados por diversos países
especialmente en África Pues bien
superada la conmoción inicial parece que
comienza a aclararse el panorama a la
vista de titulares como este compañías
militares privadas rusas se disponen a
hacerse cargo de los combatientes de
Wagner todo indica que el kremlin tiene
mucho interés en que los logros de
Wagner en África se mantengan para ello
Es probable que otros grupos de
mercenarios con notables vínculos con el
Ministerio de defensa Ruso y con los
cuerpos de inteligencia rusos pasen a
controlar buena parte del imperio
formador hasta ahora por Wagner ya se
sabe el dicho para El vencedor el botín
y también ese otro que dice el muerto al
hoyo y el vivo al boyo ahora bien He
esperado un momento amigos porque hay un
grupo de irreductibles mercenarios rusos
que no quieren dejarse dominar y están
dispuestos a pelear por la supervivencia
de Wagner por eso la pregunta es qué va
a pasar a partir de ahora con el grupo
Wagner Cómo intentará mantener el
kremlin los múltiples beneficios que las
actividades de Wagner ofrecen a la
política exterior de Rusia hoy en visual
politic vamos a dar respuesta a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de
[Música]
historia el método
Wagner Todo comenzó en Ucrania hace casi
10 años el rastro de Wagner nos lleva
hasta marzo de 2014 cuando Rusia se
anexionó la Península de crimea aquello
fue diferente a la actual invasión de
Ucrania En aquel momento en crimea
salieron de de repente de la nada los
famosos hombrecitos verdes hablamos de
soldados sin insignias ni distintivos
que el kremlin nos quiso hacer creer que
eran una especie de hombres del Bosque
simpatizantes de la causa rusa civiles
que habían tomado las armas en este
territorio a orillas del mar Negro
porque querían dejar de ser Ucrania y
unirse a la federación rusa por supuesto
la realidad era muy diferente aquellos
pequeños hombres verdes eran una mezcla
de algunos agentes de las fuerzas de
operaciones especiales y otras unidades
del servicio de inteligencia militar de
las fuerzas armadas rusas junto con
personal contratado del grupo Wagner en
otras palabras una mezcla de espías y
mercenarios justo lo que el kremlin
necesitaba para negar que los
hombrecitos verdes estaban allí
cumpliendo directamente sus
órdenes la Constitución rusa prohíbe la
creación de destacamentos armados de
carácter privado pero en el kremlin
Siempre fueron conscientes de sus
enormes beneficios la negación verosímil
es una de las grandes ventajas que
ofrece contar con compañías militares
privadas a tu servicio de la oportunidad
de intervenir allí donde los estados no
pueden actuar oficialmente y luego las
autoridades siempre pueden negar la
implicación del estado en las acciones
de estos mercenarios especialmente en
aquellas que tienen un marcado carácter
clandestino y además Las bajas no
cuentan por supuesto la ley nunca fue un
obstáculo en el kremlin solo necesitaban
a alguien que no tuviera problemas en
saltar un oligarca que actuará en las
sombras que proporcionará una fachada
empresarial Aparentemente legal para una
actividad completamente ilegal alguien
dispuesto a seguir la receta facilitada
desde los despachos donde se cocinan
este tipo de asuntos y como decimos en
visual politic dicho y hecho su hombre
era jevgeni prigo el chef de Putin dueño
del restaurante favorito del presidente
ruso el rastro del grupo Wagner post
crimea volvió a en el donbas y en
[Música]
Siria Los mercenarios de prigo jugaron
un papel destacado en la guerra
separatista del donbas que estalló
después de la anexión de crimea Asimismo
a finales de 2015 surgieron
informaciones de la participación de
mercenarios rusos en la guerra de Siria
en apoyo del régimen de basar al-assad
fue la primera vez que el grupo Wagner
utilizó la fórmula de servicios
militares a cambio de recursos naturales
en este caso a cambio de un 5% de los
ingresos de los campos de producción de
petróleo y gas recuperados al estado
[Música]
islámico sin embargo queridos amigos
África ha sido con mucha diferencia el
continente en el que más se afinó el
método Wagner después de su éxito en
Ucrania y Siria la diplomacia rusa
comenzó a ofrecer los servicios de sus
compañías militares privadas en sus
tratos con otros países siendo el grupo
Wagner su mejor exponente su primer
trabajo en África fue en la guerra de
Libia donde el grupo Wagner ha estado al
Servicio del General Rebelde xalifa
haftar Los mercenarios rusos
proporcionaron más equipos capacitación
y servicios de inteligencia a las tropas
de haftar a cambio de acceso al gas y
petróleo
[Música]
livios en los últimos años el grupo
Wagner se expandió por una docena de
países africanos con un modelo de
negocio que tiene básicamente tres
elementos el militar ofreciendo a sus
mercenarios como garantía de seguridad
para el régimen gobernante de turno el
político mediante campañas de propaganda
y desinformación e incluso organizando
grupos falsos de observadores
electorales como los de la asociación
afric que actuaron en votaciones de
países diversos como zimbabwe Madagascar
el Congo Sudáfrica y mozambique
finalmente está el elemento económico la
recompensa que estos estados ofrecen a
Wagner por sus
servicios pero esperar un momento amigos
Porque si hay un lugar en el mundo donde
los tentáculos del grupo Wagner se han
extendido hasta extremos insospechados
ese país no es otro que la República
centroafricana su presidente fostan
arcann toader había sido Primer Ministro
del país entre 2008 y 2013 cuando fue
destituido por eso cuando se hizo con el
poder al ganar las elecciones
presidenciales de 2016 zadera debió de
prometerse a sí mismo que jamás nadie
más le destituir ni siquiera el pueblo
centroafricano ya sabéis una cosa es
ganar las elecciones y otra muy distinta
arriesgarse a perderlas Así que en 2018
la República centroafricana y el kremlin
cerraron varios acuerdos bilaterales
para intercambiar oficialmente apoyo
militar y armas por concesiones mineras
entonces un antiguo oficial de
inteligencia del ejército ruso valeri
zakar pasó a ser el asesor de seguridad
Nacional del presidente tuad dera y Los
mercenarios de Wagner pasaron a integrar
su escolta personal además se estima que
el grupo Wagner desplegó hasta dos 2600
combatientes cuando surgieron en el país
grupos Rebeldes armados desde entonces
la influencia rusa ha llegado a niveles
insospechados el idioma ruso será una
materia obligatoria en las universidades
de la República centroafricana por
desgracia para la República
centroafricana uno de los países más
pobres del mundo el cultural no es el
único peaje que está pagando a Rusia la
estabilidad del presidente tuad dera en
el poder tiene un precio y este no es
precisamente barato la República
centroafricana ha puesto sus recursos
naturales a disposición de Wagner
queréis saber cómo de rentable puede ser
convertirse en el dueño de un ejército
de mercenarios Pues
[Música]
atentos el oro de
Moscú una cosa es que Vladimir Putin se
haya vengado de prigo y otra muy
distinta es que esté dispuesto a
renunciar a todo lo que los Wagner están
logrando para Rusia que es mucho África
es ahora mismo clave para el kremlin es
vital para demostrar que Rusia no se ha
quedado aislada tal y como trató de
exhibir con la Cumbre celebrada con
altos mandatarios del continente a
finales de Julio en San Petersburgo y
todo lo que Wagner ha conseguido en
África ha tenido un gran impacto a bajo
coste por ejemplo en los países en los
que opera está ayudando a expandir los
mensajes antioccidental y las conexiones
de Wagner con los caudillos africanos
pueden convertirse a futuro en una
influencia que mejore las relaciones
oficiales de estos estados con la propia
Rusia además qu dem demonios Los
mercenarios rusos entre manos tienen
proyectos demasiado fructíferos Como
para renunciar a ellos se llama
capitalismo a la rusa
amigos la República centroafricana ha
otorgado concesiones mineras de oro y
diamantes a empresas vinculadas al grupo
Wagner como mida resources entre estos
activos se encuentra la mina and sima
tiene reservas de oro por valor de más
de 1000 millones de dólares y Los
mercenarios podrán explotarla durante 25
años Boy rus otra empresa vinculada a
prig oin Recibió la concesión para
atalar diversos bosques tropicales
vírgenes dando al grupo Wagner una nueva
oportunidad de negocio de Gran potencial
la industria
maderera los cientos de empresas fachada
del grupo Wagner son fundamentales en la
estrategia del kremlin para ganar
aliados en África al mismo tiempo que
Rusia se apodera de sus recursos y
encuentra nuevas formas de evadir las
sanciones occidentales entre todos estos
recursos destaca el oro la República
centroafricana pero también en otros
países como Sudán están siendo una
fuente de oro vital para el kremlin
puesto que las reservas de oro ayudan a
Rusia a resistir el impacto de las
sanciones por la Guerra de Ucrania de
esta forma el oro africano llega a Moscú
haciendo frecuentemente la misma escala
emiratos árabes Unidos y a pesar de las
sanciones impuestas por occidente el
flujo de oro hacia Rusia continúa según
sus propios datos las reservas de oro
rusas han aumentado durante el último
año han alcanzado de hecho un máximo
histórico en 2023 tal y como podéis ver
en el siguiente gráfico que recoge los
datos trimestrales de las reservas de
oro rusas por toneladas durante las
últimas dos décadas además un informe
del parlamento británico señaló hace dos
meses que el contrabando de oro estaba
contribuyendo a sostener la economía
[Música]
rusa Pues bien Mientras tanto el método
Wagner continúa cosechando éxitos y
demostrando que es una máquina de hacer
dinero otro ejemplo concreto Pues fijaos
en Mali donde gobierna una junta militar
después de dos golpes de estado en los
últimos años todas las informaciones
apuntan a que el grupo Wagner está
cobrando una tarifa mensual de 10
millones de euros vamos ni Messi en el
Inter de Miami el objetivo de Los
mercenarios rusos en Mali es luchar
contra grupos yihadistas asociados a
alcaeda y al daes para ello hay sobre el
terreno unos 1600 efectivos de Wagner y
la junta militar de Mali debe estar
encantada con su trabajo a la vista de
que expulsaron del país a las tropas
francesas y ahora se van a marchar Los
13,000 cascos azules de la ONU después
de exigí selo al propio gobierno
maliense la junta militar ya ha elegido
su reemplazo la ONU pone fin a la misión
de mantenimiento de la paz en Mali y el
grupo Wagner se dispone a llenar el
vacío previamente un informe de la ONU
había acusado a las tropas malienses y a
Los mercenarios rusos de matar a más de
500 personas durante una operación
militar en marzo de 2022 y claro
sentirse vigilados es algo que incomoda
y mucho a las dictaduras mucho mejor
trabajar con algo así debió de pensar el
propio Vladimir Putin cuando la
población rusa mostró su incomodidad
ante la movilización parcial para la
guerra en
[Música]
Ucrania ahora bien después de años
operando bajo las sombras el presidente
Russo quiso restar méritos a prigo a
raíz de su motín y admitió que detrás de
toda la parafernalia del grupo Wagner al
final de todo estaba el propio estado
ruso
2 Wagner
262 estamos hablando de más de00
millones de en un solo año vamos que
salen más caros que el aceite de oliva
ahora bien dado que el problema para el
kremlin ha sido la creciente ambición de
prigo reemplazar al grupo Wagner o bien
integrarlo en otras compañías militares
privadas de otros oligarcas Debería ser
relativamente sencillo para los
responsables de la defensa rusa y
teniéndose en cuenta la pregunta Es
evidente Por quién y esta vez con una
segunda cuestión añadida qué rol están
dispuestos a adoptar los actuales
dirigentes de Wagner Pues bien veámoslo
El ocaso de los
[Música]
dioses el grupo Wagner quedó
completamente descabezado el pasado 23
de agosto aquel día murió
priginal Wagner así como valeri chkalov
el responsable de toda la logística del
grupo Wagner tal vez su suerte habría
sido otra si prigo se hubiera amoldado a
los planes de Putin las fechas son
importantes en esta secuencia de los
hechos el motín fallido se produjo los
días 23 y 24 de junio luego el día 29 en
el encuentro que tuvieron en el kremlin
Putin sugirió que el Antiguo Coronel
andrey trev debía ser el nuevo líder de
Wagner frigoin se negó y optó por llevar
sus mercenarios a Bielorrusia incluso
aumentó su afrenta a Putin expulsando a
trev de Wagner el 30 de junio el grupo
Wagner despide a uno de sus cinco
líderes un ex Coronel del ejército ruso
diversas informaciones indican que troch
se negó a participar en el motín de
Wagner e incluso señalan que avisó al
kremlin de la rebelión que estaba
cocinando prigo trev es un Coronel
retirado veterano de la invasión
soviética de Afganistán y de Las Guerras
rusas en chechenia al parecer se había
convertido en el hombre de confianza de
pein en Siria y ahora Putin quería
recompensar su lealtad otorgándole el
liderazgo del grupo de mercenarios como
si Wagner fuera una empresa Estatal más
pero a la hora de la verdad no pudo
imponer su decisión no obstante es un
tipo de información que tampoco debemos
descartar que el kremlin sea el
principal interesado en
divulgar que el kremin exhiba la
capacidad de nombrar al jefe del grupo
Wagner es una opción poco conveniente
sobre todo después de reconocer que la
financia el presupuesto Estatal
nacionalizar al grupo Wagner no es
interesante ni para la propia Rusia que
no podría negar su implicación en las
atrocidades cometidas por Wagner ni
tampoco para los gobiernos africanos que
tienen más fácil argument ar que el país
está bajo su control si lo que contratan
son mercenarios en lugar de fuerzas que
responden directamente ante las
autoridades de Estados
[Música]
extranjeros por este motivo parece
Sensato pensar que al kremlin le
interesaría más un grupo Wagner más
parecido al de sus orígenes un grupo de
mercenarios sobre el que circulan muchos
rumores y pocas certezas Un regreso a
las sombras con el que recuperar la
negación verosímil en este caso los
actuales mercenarios de Wagner pueden
ser contrat dados por otra compañía
militar privada y sus operaciones
globales continuar bajo un liderazgo más
favorable al Ministerio de defensa Ruso
y aquí es donde vuelve a cobrar
relevancia la figura del Coronel
trev acaba de encontrar trabajo y nos ha
colocado sobre la pista de quién podría
heredar el Imperio creado por prigo
utkin y chkalov fuera bagner entra redut
surge una nueva empresa militar privada
en Rusia bajo el control directo del
kremlin de redut se sabe que trabajó en
la seguridad de proyectos de
infraestructura en Siria dirigidos por
esty transgas una empresa de ingeniería
vinculada al sector petrolero y gacía
por el grupo volga del oligarca yenadi
timeto también que después de contratar
a trev redut Está tratando de reclutar
personal de Wagner y combatientes con
experiencia para luchar en Ucrania y
podrían expandirse Próximamente al
continente africano ya que si eres un
líder africano que necesita hombres
armados lo que menos te importa es si su
insignia pone redut o Wagner algo así ya
expresó a finales de junio un alto cargo
del gobierno de la República
centroafricana en declaraciones a la
agencia afp la República centroafricana
firmó un acuerdo de defensa con la
federación rusa y no con Wagner Rusia ha
subcontratado a Wagner si Rusia ya no
está de acuerdo con Wagner Entonces nos
enviará un nuevo contingente reemplazar
a Wagner por redut garantizaría a Rusia
mantener el control de las minas y los
recursos naturales que están en manos de
Los mercenarios rusos pero es un momento
amigos porque el grupo Wagner no ha
dicho aún su última palabra todavía hay
un grupo de reductibles que se plantea
vengar la muerte de
priginal el nuevo Señor de la guerra del
grupo Wagner al asumir Lotus el cargo de
jefe Mercenario Lotus es como llaman a
anton y elizarov También conocido como
El conquistador de Soledad se trata de
un fiel colaborador de prigi en los
escenarios más complicados como Siria o
Ucrania pero hay que ser realistas lo lo
más probable es que Los mercenarios de
Wagner se inclinen más por garantizar su
propia supervivencia antes que por
desafiar a Putin permaneciendo leales a
un líder muerto pero ahora la pregunta
es para todos vosotros creéis que redut
será una compañía militar privada tan
exitosa como la construida por prigsa
que optará por un perfil más discreto
como el de los orígenes del grupo Wagner
podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo Dale al
botón de like y no olvides suscribirte
avisa al politic si es no lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la
próxima